The mic.
Yes.
Yeah, so welcome back to this session.
So today I have planned a few.
Again, on the second module only,
but it is more on when we are augmenting
AI to every SDLC phase,
there are new terms which are coming up.
There is,
we were talking about how the role of a
developer or a software architect or a
software engineer in general is shift.
Thing, so we will be looking at that now,
so let me just...
Check if recording is done. Yes, OK.
Okay, so a few updates.
I have shifted this class to 1030 to 1230
as many of you had requested and they
have done it.
So we'll continue with this slot going
forward. And the quiz.
Is open, so those who haven't attempted,
I think, should finish it off.
I think the last date is over or yet to
be over. I think this...
tomorrow or tomorrow.
So those who haven't,
ensure you are doing it.
And also I have posted a few,
two questions as a sample for you all to
have an understanding.
So,
we'll have till module only three modules
for the examination. OK,
because we have to cover a lot of
prerequisites,
and plus we have spent a considerable
amount of time in understanding.
the AI as such, the fundamentals,
as well as how the shift is happening,
Like.
which will help us to navigate through
the phases at a much faster phase.
We are spending a little more time in the
initial modules, which is completely fine.
So
We have two more classes,
6 and today is 6,
so seven and eight are the two classes
before the mid sem examination.
So where we will cover only requirements
and design pattern. So one module one,
two and three,
that would be the syllabus for your
examination.
upcoming mid-semester closed book
examination.
So I've given a little idea about what
kind of questions you will be expect.
So the sample questions,
two questions I have posted in the Ms.
TEAMS shared folder,
just for your reference.
To give you an idea,
That.
The questions are not going to be asking
you what is what or a definition.
It is going to be a scenario and you are
going to apply concepts.
It is going to be more of not just
focusing on one concept.
So the same scenario which I posted,
I can even use it for more questions.
I have given you 2 questions.
There is one scenario I have given,
I have given two questions and another
scenario I have given,
I have given three questions there.
But the same scenario can be extended and
it can be.
posted to many other questions checking
your basic understanding about the shift.
So basically what you have to concentrate
on is what is the SDLC which has been
evolved? What is the shift? Where are we?
The.
Um...
What are what is the shift affecting?
at all phases,
not only on when I say all phases,
I shouldn't actually use the word phases.
What is the shift is affecting right from
a role of what a developer is doing plus.
the cost plus the work we do,
plus the infrastructure we need.
So it's affecting many things.
So you should, we discussed many shifts.
So you should understand the shifts and
then you should understand what are the
risks,
what are the things we have to work on in
the future, or what
What are we?
as software developers should take
accountability for. So the risks involved,
how it can be mitigated is something we
have not discussed in detail,
Really?
but we have of course looked at most
probable best practices so you can have
an idea about that.
So that is what is your understanding
should about.
And of course, the terms,
the new terms is something very necessary,
like what is token,
what is context window, what is a model,
what is an AI agent,
and whatever we are going to discuss
today.
So these are the things which we can have
an understanding.
So this is what mainly will.
You have to have to prepare yourselves
for the Ms. examination as such. OK,
so with that note,
I let's get into today's.
topic. So I'll start with agent today.
So any questions before,
can you please paste the SharePoint link?
The entire folder is not visible to you.
No, ma'am.
Entire folders should be shared, isn't it?
You.
It is in the class, yeah,
some of them are unable to see it,
probably. SNEHA should check.
I have anyway posted it also.
Like, uh, you can check.
Okay.
So, so far we have been seeing about.
The.
model, right? What is a model?
What is a foundation model?
What is a large language model?
How it transitioned into a large
reasoning model? All that, right?
So now what is an agent?
That is where we have to go because
mostly today we have agents.
Right, so what exactly is agent?
How it is actually used in software
industry today?
That is what we have to look at.
So first, tell me when.
Yeah.
Yeah, OK. Anyone had question?
So what is the agent according to your
understanding?
We have heard of the still agent, yes,
yes, I've been out of it.
Yes, ma'am.
So agent is something like if you talk
about just generative AI,
it helps in generating content or
generating artifacts, resources for us.
But what if like if we want to want the
AI system to take autonomous actions,
right,
and not just stop at creating things,
right?
So that is what we call them as agent,
which can.
Reason it out, plan,
and then take real action for on behalf
of human,
so that is what we now understand in the
Great.
agent.
Yeah,
so you are linking agents to an
autonomous behavior, right?
It can do something which we require to
do apart just more than doing a chat
response to us, right? Yeah, that's right.
So you can see the word autonomous itself
there in the definition. An AI agent is a.
..
at an enormous software entity,
which means it can work on its own to a
certain extent based on the autonomy
level we give it to it, right? That's so,
have you all heard about agent or
anything related to agent before this AI
agent or agent era?
I would say we have few agents, right?
No.
Any example?
Anyone heard of agents before the AI
agents we are talking about?
And normally, like, security agent,
ROHIT agent, maybe.
The human agents.
Yeah.
Human legends.
Okay, human agents. Yeah, okay.
Agents who help to get the passport,
or you know, the driving license, those,
And and.
Travel agents, right? Yeah. Okay.
So in human life, real time,
yeah.
Seven.
if you go outside the digital sector,
we have people called as agent because
they are specific to do certain things.
They are carrying forward certain
information.
from the particular association they are
with,
and they come and act autonomously to do
get things done, right? So travel agents,
et cetera. But in digital or in software,
have you heard of AI agents before the AI?
place, anywhere.
Logging agent, okay.
e-mail notification, telementary agents.
Yes. So agent, yeah.
So now I think most of you got it right.
So agent is not something new, right?
Agent always has been something which can
do a work,
a specific set of work on its own.
But it has been programmed or designed to
do so, right? So it will work on its own.
It has a little autonomy.
So from the beginning,
there has been some autonomy given to the
agent and it has worked through it.
Now what we are talking is AI agents.
So that's why I'm specifically adding AI
because these terms keep changing.
You go to literature.
Sorry, go to web search now. Of course,
we are not doing web search or we the AI
mode is actually covering up the basic
web search which has been there,
but if you look at a web search,
which apart from the AI agents has,
Hello.
we have been having agents meet.
in many places.
We had agent-based services,
we had agent in service-oriented
architecture when we wanted to actually
have an enterprise service-oriented.
There were certain agents responsible for
certain things, right? So,
but all of your understanding about what
an agent is is correct.
So agents are not something new to
software.
Like, what is?
AI agent is, it's again a software entity,
as all of you said.
It is designed to do a particular task.
It has three main things. One,
it has a set of information, a perceived,
it has an understanding of certain
information which it receives.
through data inputs, et cetera.
So it has some information and it makes
decisions.
So this making decision part is what is
new in the AI agent.
If you look at the previous agents which
are there,
they were rule based or they worked based
on the program they were.
designed with.
But now here they do a little bit of
reasoning because they are associated
with the language model or a reasoning
model.
So they make decisions based on what is
coming out of it.
And then based on the response,
they execute actions. So they also,
so when I say execute actions,
they just know.
Yeah.
model.
So they have to interface with many other
tools to achieve what the agent is
designed for.
So if you look at a traditional...
Software that follows static rules, etc.
They are chat based.
They don't go above it. For example,
I ask if I want,
say I have written a piece of function in
Python and I want it.
to be debugged.
I wanted to check what is the error in it.
If I have to use ChatGPT,
I have to paste the code in ChatGPT or
Gemini, whatever it is, and I've asked,
what is the error? Can you help me?
So it will run through that code example.
It might execute in its interpreter based
on how the ChatGPT.
Is built on top of the language model,
and it will only give me a response in
the text format in the,
so that's a chat-based interface, right?
So now, if I want,
if I run a copilot or a clot, I have,
say I have a Visual Studio code running.
and I am working on a front end web
application and I want to debug or find
out the error or execute it.
AI agents can read the files.
It can identify the problem,
it can correct, go and correct it.
and then it can execute it.
So it can do much more than what a chat
based interface can do.
That is what we say in the agent.
So it works in a loop.
It first understands,
that's the perception it creates,
it perceives information.
then it doesn't have intelligence on its
own.
It actually refers to a language model
only, LLM or any model.
I don't want to associate agents only
with LLM,
so I will keep it specific as generic as
a model because there can be agents which
can be built out of.
any other model,
not only a large language model.
So let's say a model.
So the model is going to bring in the
intelligence or how it's going to react
to it.
Then the steps are defined again in the
agent. So this is the basic step.
Evaluate is an additional step.
which we are working towards.
So it doesn't stop there.
It goes back and evaluates what response
comes out of it,
checks if it matches what it has to
achieve,
or does it converge to the goal it has to
achieve. If not, it again evaluates,
go backs again, and acts on it.
So that is out.
the loop is continuously rapid. Right?
So the term agent has been used in
different engineering contexts,
not limited to an intelligent agent or a
software agent.
So we have a software agent,
we have conversational agents,
we have a reinforcement learning agent,
et cetera.
So in general,
an agent is that can perceive its
environment, act upon that.
So an agent is characterized by the
environment it operates in, right?
So an environment an agent can operate in
defines the use case, right?
If an agent is developed to play a game,
right? That game is its environment.
If an agent,
if you want an agent to scrap documents,
web documents from the internet,
the environment is the internet, right?
If the agent is a cooking robot,
then the kitchen is the environment or
the device it has access to.
That is the environment, right?
If in a self-driving car,
agent's environment is the access to the
car and the road system itself.
So the set of actions an agent can
perform.
is something it cannot do only with the
model.
So it has to be Augmented by the tools it
has access to.
So many chat, even ChatGPT is an agent.
We don't actually say.
The GPT4 is the LLM. GPT,
whatever GPT version is behind the
ChatGPT is the LLM.
So many generative AI powered
applications we interact with daily are
agents.
With access to the...
models. So ChatGPT itself is an agent.
It can search the web,
it can execute a Python code,
it can generate images.
Right? So that's what is an agent.
So there is a strong,
if you look at the statements which I'm
making, you can see that the environment,
the set of tools,
play a very major part of the agents.
Life Cycle or how a agent is,
so the environment determines what tools
an agent can potentially.
Use right, so, and...
Agent has to operate.
That.
within a specific explicit boundary,
which is set by the design and publish.
Now, in the enterprise.
And we say we are developing an agent,
right?
It is mostly automating a well-scoped
task.
Take off,
I would request others to be on mute if
you don't have questions.
So if an agent,
say there is a well-defined scope task
and we want to automate that,
like say for example,
retrieving a record from a system,
validating that data and routing that
request,
say that there is an API request coming
into an API gateway and you want to route
it to the right microservice.
etc. It's very,
it's like automating a task.
An agent can do it with a simple
rule-based system or simple logic defined,
etc. Right?
So AI agents operate with explicit
boundaries set by their design and
permissions.
AI agent can use rules,
it can use machine learning models,
it can use large language models,
it can use natural language processing to
interpret inputs and make decisions,
and they often interact with the tools to
carry out the actions.
So if I say an access management agent,
it will process the software request,
check for eligibility in the database,
verify permissions,
and then it will update the information.
A finance agent or an agent running with
the invoices might extract data from the
invoices.
compare it with the policies and then
might provide an information.
So every agent is designed to perform a
specific function.
It can also serve as a building block for
many larger or multi-agent systems or
agent DKI systems.
Now, on a simple thing,
agents excel at a focused automation.
They are good at one thing,
they are focused. But individually,
they are not designed to orchestrate
end-to-end workflows that span across
multiple systems.
or they are all based on static planning
only. They by default or agent,
one agent as such has not been planned
for dynamic planning. And it has not been.
able or it will not be able to address
coordination,
governance or other reasoning layers.
Like it has one,
it has been designed with one flow,
so it will operate with autonomy inside
that defined boundaries only. OK,
so that is where we have to,
that is where our role as a software
engineers or humans will come in.
So AI agents, how it works specifically,
here is one example which I have taken
from the book AI Engineering.
So this is some example of a software
engineering agent. It's a coding agent.
And from the picture,
you can see that what it has access to.
It has access to its entire environment
is the computer, so it can search files,
it can navigate the repo,
it can view files, and it can edit lines.
So it has access to the computer,
the terminal, the file system.
And these are the actions that you can.
perform.
So this agent is built on top of GPT-4.
Its environment is the computer with the
terminal and the file system.
And the set of actions it can perform is
navigate, search files, view files,
and edit lines.
So this is what the agent is built to do.
So,
each one is built with the to understand
a specific input. So, in this case,
the input is only the set of files and
these reports.
Determine the appropriate next step and
take action within the constraints of
this design.
An agent can make decisions,
but only for the task or the slice of
work it is responsible for.
So some agents behave reactively,
they respond to users' prompts or system
events. Others are
They have some of them can be planned,
allowing them to follow a multi-step
sequence also.
But even the most capable agent remains
scoped to their domains. So it is,
it can be a chat interface like in
Copilot, we have this chat,
you can ask it to do a certain thing,
it can respond to you.
or it can also go and edit the code file,
etc. Even Copilot,
I'm talking about GitHub Copilot,
and I'm also talking about if you have a
Copilot view with the Word or PPT,
you can ask it to change a few things.
There is two options, chat only and edit.
mode right?
So chat only means it's going to respond
to you and it means it's going to go and
change a few things.
on it.
So it can have a simple multi-step
sequences also,
but it is spoke only to that particular
domain.
They are not designed to coordinate
complex workflows across systems, etc.
So having...
Set that.
You can have multiple agents for doing
different tasks.
Right, so I can have multiple agents,
but having multiple agents alone doesn't
make you a agentic AI system.
Multi-agent system or orchestration or an
agentic AI system requires a.
planning, coordination, and a reasoning,
a goal directed reasoning across agents.
Right, so that is the next layer.
But basically this is what an agent is.
Now, in real world,
we have many types of agents.
So I have listed down a few agents.
Simple.
reflex agents,
which are big simple agents,
which existed even before the AI era,
like they are rule based.
It strictly goes through a simple rule
system, right?
These agents respond directly to incoming
inputs or events.
It is event-based using predefined rules.
So many of our IT troubleshooting agents
which were there,
when an employee says that there is a VPN
issue or there is a networking issue,
et cetera,
all these IT troubleshooting agents,
they perform a series of steps and that
is how.
it works.
So these are reactive reflective agents.
It reacts to an immediate current
perception and it is based on the rules.
Next is a model based reflex agent.
So this agents maintain an internal
representation of the
environment,
allowing them to make more informed
decisions. So it takes decisions. It has,
it maintains an internal state,
the perception I said,
it perceives certain things, right,
information from the environment.
So it has that information, plus it.
goes to a model which has a little
intelligence,
I would say little or more depending on
the model, and it reacts to it, right? So.
..
A security agent that updates decisions
based on the changing user context or a
finance agent that validates invoices,
an automated braking system that accounts
for bed Rd. conditions, etc. These are,
because why do we say an automated
braking system that for bed Rd.
conditions means?
You cannot define certain conditions as
we discussed in the initial class when we
are talking about rule-based AI and the
symbolic AI and the other AI.
Basically,
you cannot write everything in terms of
rules, right?
We need a little more understanding there.
So that is why model becomes useful.
The next is a goal-based agent.
So when I say goal, it is like planning.
You go and...
define a target state.
This is what I want to achieve, right?
You equip them with the need of the
whatever it requires to achieve that.
And it will not be a linear path.
It might be having multiple diversions.
It might have to,
it has to choose paths based on the
results of the previous path, et cetera.
like our flow charts, right?
So it has to choose actions explicitly at
various stages to achieve a desired state.
So that's a goal-based agent.
And then utility,
goal and utility are together mostly same,
but these agents.
Utility agents weigh the potential
outcomes to choose the next action,
and they choose the one that offers the
highest value based on a predefined
criteria, so...
Say there is a support agent that
determines the escalation priority of
tickets coming in based on risk,
urgency and past resolution patterns.
So that's a utility agent, right?
And how well or efficiently a goal is
reached using a utility function.
That is what is the decision here.
So goal-based and utility,
you will see a major overlap because some
books don't have a goal-based agent or
utility agent separately.
They have it in the same, but Gemini,
when I asked for the type of agent,
it generated one more.
version, so I just kept it as it is.
But mostly they are the same.
A support agent or a workflows,
say there is a workforce planning agent
that has to allocate training resources
based on many skills and based on many
other factors.
is designed for only that particular work.
And it has to take a lot of decisions
based on values at each step.
So that is what a utility agent is.
And learning agents are the agents which
improve over time by having a feedback
loop based on the outcomes.
feedback or new data.
It has certain capability to learn.
So a knowledge retrieval agent that
refines relevance ranking based on search
pattern,
a customer support agent that adapts to
the
issues or trends which are happening,
the recommendation engines which many of
the ODT sites and which have.
So they operate in a way that they can
adapt behavior-based feedback which is
coming and they can.
improve themselves.
So AI agents come in different forms,
but they are designed in different forms,
each designed to handle a specific style
of decision making or interaction.
And these categories, which we discussed,
are basically related to the enterprise
automation.
You will see many of these agents used
across many enterprise workflows,
real-time workflows, etc.
Across this each categories,
you will see that one thing is common,
that each agent is typically designed for
a specific slice of work.
even when multiple agents are deployed
together.
And even when they interact with several
systems,
they require tools or orchestration to
operate across tools and goals, etc.
There are many, I mean,
these names you see,
different companies follow a different
name. So some of them have
agents,
some of them call their agents as action
agents because they perform certain or
they execute certain tasks on behalf of
the user with precision.
So they translate a user request into an
automated action and they do it.
So those are called as action agents.
Some of them are called as aggregation
agents also because they go through a lot
of information by gathering the data,
then they synthesize,
analyze the data and present relevant
data to the user.
So those are called as aggregation agents.
There are
ambient agents,
that is agents which work in the
background silently.
They constantly monitor the environment.
They look at resource utilization,
they look at how they respond to signals,
and they kind of move more on
observability side.
So there are ambient agents.
So there are many agents,
the names based on what it is designed
for.
So generally it is utility model based
and learning.
Right.
So these specialized agents work to
achieve a larger goal together.
So you have to coordinate,
make a coordination among them, et cetera.
And in the modern agentic systems which
we are having,
if you look at the other category,
the type of agents, right,
They are single task autonomous agents.
It is equipped with specific tools.
To accomplish a multi-step objectives,
so say our example of coding-based agents
or web scrapping research bots, like...
Then if you look at multi-agent networks,
so there is a single task autonomous
agent, which does only one work, right?
And then there is a multi-agent network,
systems where specialized agents
collaborate. So if you look at AWS Kero,
I don't know if I have given this link to
you earlier. If not,
also I will just give it.
So Kiro is a platform by AWS which moves
AI coding to agentic engineering, right?
It
three or four different agents.
When I read it had three,
I don't know if they have agents.
So there is one agent which works on the
code side.
There is another agent which works on the
testing side.
So they have the parallel agents which
can work together.
Right? So that is a multi-agent system,
multi-agent networks.
So you have a coder agent working
alongside a reviewer agent and a tester
agent.
And they work across a set of information
or a graph or a state graph.
So that is a multi-agent network.
And then there are hierarchical.
So in this multi-agent itself,
when I say an individual agent,
it works to do a specific task.
And when multiple agents are there,
it can be a simple linear one.
One agent finishes the task,
it passes on to the other.
This agent finishes the task,
passes on to the other.
Or it can be they can run parallelly.
Each of them can run parallelly also,
and they converge at one point.
Or there can be a master,
a controller agent,
breaks down tasks for specialized agent
and hands it over to the other task.
So the controller agent is the one which
issues the task on what the other
agents should do to sub-agents.
So this approach is also possible.
So when I say multi-agent,
then many things are possible.
So, based on what they are doing,
different names will come into that there.
Now, most coding tools,
what we have right, Claude.
GitHub Copilot. See, if I say,
if you ask me what cloud code,
what type of agent it is,
or GitHub Copilot,
what kind of code it is?
It depends on how we look at the division,
right? If you look at the table which I'm.
..
describing here, this table,
and ask me what agent Claude belongs to.
It is utility and goal-based together.
The primary classification would be
utility because it evaluates trade-offs
to pick the optimal path.
It checks for code correctness.
It reads the information.
It also ensures style consistency to
produce the result, etc.
And it is also goal-based because you are
saying fix this problem,
fix this debugging or refactor the module.
So it has a step-by-step plan to
transform the current code into a.
the target state.
So it is also goal based and utility
based.
This is the primary classification I
would say. In a modern...
taxonomy or in a different level of say
if I want to categorize the coding tools
by the interaction model they make or in
the level of autonomy they have.
Right,
because if I take a cloud code or GitHub
coding as its agent or whatever,
it has inline completion,
it has an interactive agent,
it can work autonomously, asynchronously,
it has autocomplete mode, et cetera,
right? So it has.
real-time collaboration,
so it is interactive.
It can work alongside using your agent
mode, so it has,
so autonomy level is from low to medium.
It can act as a navigator,
it can act as a driver, right?
So it can delegate.
the task,
it can work with the CLI or a cloud
environment.
So it can run an autonomous loop,
a react loop.
We were talking about in the previous
step I was talking, right?
It can read the repository,
it can plan changes, it can execute edits,
it can run test suits in the terminal.
So that is what it can be configured to
do.
So the autonomy level can still remain
low by just interacting in a real-time
collaboration, or it can go above.
to a medium where it can act with the CLI
or the autonomy level can go to high like
you delegate a goal leap and review the
final output.
Like it can go to each level depending on
how you are using,
but the capability is there with the
agent, right?
So if you generally ask me what is the
classification in the list of agent types
I have mentioned,
I will say goal based or utility based
agent. But if you look at.
the modern taxonomies or how we are using
agents in real life today. GitHub Copilot,
in a very chat based mode or in a plot
mode when you ask for some information,
it can work as a simple interactive
reflex
assistant or it can be a complete
autonomous agent,
goal based agent as well.
Right, if you interact,
if you have it in a very simple reflexive
assistant mode, you have a chat interface,
you just need an IDE.
Mhm.
But if it has to be in the goal based
mode, you will need much more.
You need access to the cloud or you need
access to the CLI, et cetera. In a simple.
A chat interface, the introduction,
a single step.
prompt and you get the response.
Here it is multi-step, it plans, acts,
absorbs and repeat it. Right?
So that is what is the difference.
So when I say plainly it is an agent,
but what level of autonomy it has,
what kind of work it is doing can change.
Based on what you are doing.
Yeah, so there is a question from Sirisha.
Are learning agents the most dangerous?
Again,
what is the level of autonomy you have
given it to? Right, are they, say I ask,
I give it a goal,
to do a certain task. It plans, it acts,
it absorbs, and it repeats.
No, no.
So the repeat is there.
So is it going to stop at what point that
if it is not defined and it has complete
access?
So you would have experienced some of you
were trying with plot code or GitHub
Copilot.
It'll get into a continuous loop
sometimes. Have you all noticed?
You actually, you would have seen,
you would be seeing that the work you
asked for has been done,
but still it gets into a continuous loop.
It starts reasoning it.
So you won't know why it is doing that,
right?
Or probably there is no human in the loop.
which actually stops it unless you ask it
to stop it, right?
It gets into a continuous loop,
doing things, rechecking,
because it's maybe looking at some
parameter which it has to satisfy, etc.
Right,
so the autonomy is that is what matters,
what access it has, what autonomy it has,
how do you control?
Right.
So the open AI question which you are
asking is much more.
It's not just an agent there.
The group of AI agents hacking another
set of agents is, I mean,
I cannot just say they are just learning
agents.
They are more, they have more autonomy,
plus they are a multi-agent system.
They have been interacting with each
other.
So when you have a multi-agent system,
there has to be a way in which they
coordinate. So as I told you,
individual agents, they work.
Well, you can define how they work well,
but when multiple agents are there,
one reasoning or one response affects the
other.
You don't have a human who says, okay,
this is right, go ahead.
You have another agent which says,
this is right, go ahead.
So that is the multi-agent coordination
is what would be the problem there.
And it is much more than a learning agent
there.
Okay,
so harness is the next thing we have to
talk about. Right, so what is agent?
So I told it has reasoning capability,
it has autonomy, right?
The name given to building an agent
around the model.
to do a specific task,
that is what harness is engineering about.
And this name has come up. So this is the,
I don't know who developed the name,
I think.
Okay,
I think Lamb chain and together they have
designed the me probably.
Okay,
so harness is a very new name which came
in only in 2026.
We have been talking about building
agents or we have been talking about how
do you provide data to the agents or how
do you provide
access to the agent for different tools,
etc. How do you control it, right?
So the name given to that is the harness.
So when you say agent,
it has the access to a model.
So we keep it very generic.
We are not saying it is a large language
model, reasoning model, etc.
So it has access to a model.
plus the harness.
The harness is the one which enables the
access to the tools environment,
plus the action, the autonomy it can take.
So harness engineering is about how we
build the environment around the AI model.
to turn it into a autonomous,
reliable agent.
So the model will give you the
intelligence,
while harness will provide everything the
model cannot do, like execution,
CLI command execution,
access to the tools, reading the files,
the permissions, the validations.
All these are given by B.
So software engineers today spend a lot
of time on harness engineering.
So anyone who's creating an agent,
they initially during the design phase,
they design,
they think about what model they can go
with, how to.
Connect with it, etc.,
but they spend more time in the other
part of what it the model can be given
access to.
An agent is a model plus the partners.
A model only takes in text input and
returns text.
It or it for any question you ask,
it gives a response.
It doesn't hold any state across steps.
It doesn't execute code.
It doesn't read from database or it
cannot enforce a permission.
Every useful thing an agent does,
the harness is.
the one which is doing the heavy lifting
through code configuration and execution
logic wrapped around the model.
Two teams, you would have heard of this.
Two teams can run the exact same model
and they can get very different results.
So, earlier, when we say that the...
They used to give the credit to prompt
engineering, right?
So I have a slide on prompt engineering
also.
But today,
the harness is the gap or the harness is
the decision.
When 2 teams runs the exact model and get
different results,
the gap between them is the harness and
not about the model.
So earlier we used to ask question,
which AI model writes the best code?
And then it shifted to how do you write
to the AI model?
Prompt engineering is about how do you
write to the AI model,
which gives you the best code, right?
And next it was about context engineering.
How do we feed the right context, right?
So that was the questions which we will
be discussing in detail.
But today, how do the question is,
how do we operationalize AI agent?
The harness is the answer. The harness.
And it is not the model that determines
how well an AI coding agent or AI agent
works in production.
So, if you take a coding agent,
all AI coding tools can generate code at
this point,
a lot of it on a very quick layer.
Yet more code doesn't mean better code or
better outcome, right?
AI adoption is producing code changes.
that are larger, more complex,
and good enough than before.
At the same time,
the quality of AI generative code makes
it cognitively taxing to review.
Engineers have to,
we have been discussing this problem for
a very long time. Engineers have to.
To hunt for subtle errors in code,
they have to review it;
they should have a knowledge of a senior
developer to read through it,
review a fatigue sets in,
they sometimes mistakes slip through,
right? So, unvetted.
code enters the production.
So, this is the problem,
but if you can feed the model better
context.
Can it solve the problem?
to a certain extent, but not completely.
We need a verification.
So how do you verify?
So you have to build the model gives you
the answer.
The harness is the one that can give you
whether the reasoning the model gave is
reliable and actionable.
Several failure modes.
which are there to the AI models.
If you can name a few,
what are the anthropic game list of
failure modes that are inherent to the AI
models? Anxiety, context anxiety,
hallucination, bias.
So these are some problems.
We have heard of these problems,
or you might have encountered these
problems when using AI models, et cetera.
Agents frequently will say that the task
is completed without verifying a task
when the token is going to be out of.
this thing, right?
And some models will panic and rush to
finish because it's running out of space
or tokens.
And agents try to tackle an entire
problem in one go without thinking a
step-by-step approach. So
All this was the reason where in around
in February 2026 or March 2026,
launching engineering team.
came up with this concept of RNS
engineering.
So they said that they moved their entire
coding agent from the 30th place to 5th
place on the terminal bench on some
benchmarking without changing the
underlying model,
but only working on improving the harness
around it.
Right,
so that is what harness a well-built
harness gives us many inputs,
many information in which the agent can
be controlled.
So we have to spend a lot of time on
harness. Of course,
when we are doing every SBLC phase,
we will spend on it.
But I would like to differentiate the
types of harness. When I say harness,
it's not just one control.
It's much more than that. It's a whole.
amount of software engineering which is
associated with that.
So there is something called a pre-built
harness or custom harness or in sometimes
some words you can call it as coding
harness, user harness, etc.
When there are general purpose execution
capabilities that are configured,
that becomes pre-built harnesses,
and the engineering teams,
they build their custom
organization-specific compliance, safety,
and accountability,
all those things outside it.
So most coding agents we have today,
they have a default harness built around
it, right? So Cloud Code is one example.
It comes with a basic harness like file
read write tools,
the ability to run terminal commands.
It uses a multi-step execution loop.
It has permission controls that prompt
for human approval before taking some
quick, risky actions.
So that is the default harness.
What makes it an agent rather than a chat
bot? It can take actions,
it can check results,
it can keep going until a task is done,
but it comes with a pre-built default
harness. But the default harness is
This is starting point;
it is not a finished product at all,
because as an engineering team who has
been working on an enterprise software
for a very long,
the software engineers or the team has a
lot of information it can harness into
the system, right? So,
engineering teams routinely have...
to layer additional information on top of
it to fit their environment,
a specific environment,
their own standards and risks tolerance.
So this is where harness engineering has
a discipline itself really begins.
Consider a company like a mid-sized
FinTech company.
who's trying to adopt A copilot or a
cloud code across their back-end
engineering team.
So the default harness provides the basic
thing,
but the team also requires additional
requirements that default harness doesn't
cover. Every, say for example,
it's a finance.
FinTech company, right?
So it should have every PR touching the
payment logic.
must go through a proprietary compliance
check or a compliance linter before it
can be submitted.
And agents should never modify database
migration files without a human sign-off.
There can be many things you can build on
a custom harness.
Been built around.
and all activity needs to be,
you can say that all activity of the
agent needs to be logged into an internal
audit system for regulatory review.
So there are many things you can write on
top of it.
None of these exist in the default
harness.
So the engineering team has to build it.
So they build a custom layer that sits
between the agent and their code base,
enforcing these rules on every run.
The model hasn't changed.
The plot code's default harness hasn't
changed. What changed is the additional.
scaffolding the team build around it.
So this layered model is common and
intentional and that is what is we are
talking about in harness engineering.
And tools like Cloud Code or any coding
agent tools or any agent should be
extended through mechanisms
like this.
So it's not only enforcing standards or
enforcing compliance,
it is about tool access also.
So I want to provide a.
access to a proprietary database or a
ticketing system or through an MCP server
which allows the team to plug in new
tools the agents can call.
So that also I have to build an harness
around it, how it acts,
checks the internal APIs or how it goes
and reads the database, etc.
Right, so a Claude.nd file is created,
so next week we will,
when we have a good understanding of this,
when we move to module 3,
we will start with the AI native life
cycle, and if you all have read the news,
etc., Claude has released a.
Playbook.
May I need to?
I think AI native SDLC playbook. Yeah,
I think very recently.
I'm just posting the link in the chat.
We will cover this in detail sometime
later.
So it starts with planning.
So in planning, what you do,
you write these specifications.
So there is a plot.md file,
which I will be writing to actually give
all this information.
So default harness will be there inside.
but a claude.
md file in the repository will write all
the team specific instructions into every
session.
It will function as a harness
customization around the module. Okay,
so Claude will write the code,
a second agent will review.
and it will check all this before the PR
is opened, etc.
So what a production ready coding agent
harness contains is tool orchestration it
should have.
So for example,
when I say an agent is going to
production,
I'm going to create an agent and put it
into production, right?
It's not byte coding.
So if you have heard,
if you have been following stories,
the term byte coding was released 1 1/2
years, two years back, I think.
Um...
by Andridge. And if you look at,
there were many examples.
Every people started sharing examples of
how they did VYOM code. In a weekend,
they built an application.
And we had also heard stories about how
the entire database was wiped out by a
VYOM coding.
A system, I think one company,
I forgot the name,
but when white coding was introduced,
they were using.
The entire database was removed off,
the production database was removed off
by an agent completely.
So there are many mistakes which have
happened,
many unrecoverable errors also could have
happened. So that's how it was.
But now we are not in that stage.
We a production ready agent, it has to go.
We have to engineer and harness around it,
right? The harness has to have.
guardrails, tool orchestration.
When I say guardrails,
it should have human in the loop approval
gates, budget ceilings,
hard coded boundary limits.
many more, right?
We will look at what all guardrails are
necessary at each phase, etc,
but it should have that.
And in context and memory,
it should give what all is needed to
eliminate repeated overhead prompting,
etc.
Tool what all tools it needs access to,
what execution shells it needs.
Are there going to be audit tracing logs,
observability?
So how it should log every information,
every input, output,
and the state of the agent in a log
system? All that has to be.
given.
So harness is a broad term and we can
split it into levels.
So a simple level is coding harness,
user harness,
and the SDLC as a whole as an
organizational harness. But it is not,
I mean you can.
give different names to it or categorize
different to it. But in simple terms,
I would say there is a default harness
which comes with the model itself.
So the coding harness, it is shipped,
every agent is shipped with something
basic, right?
And user harness is what you as a user
wanted.
So,
you use Cloud MD or tools specification
on top of it,
and you provide your own convention files,
your MCP server connections,
your custom skills review agents, etc.
And then...
The SDLC harness that.
It can be a governance agents across
teams.
It can talk about human in the loop
checkpoints. It can talk about.
the integrations, agent registry,
entire governance as such,
which is much more about the individual
agent or as a team itself,
the platform around the agent can be
discussed.
So, a well-built...
Hardness is something which is required.
For a.
Hardness to get into a production, sorry,
for an agent to get into a production.
Right, so this diagram, I would,
there is one article which I have given
in the references.
This is by Martin Fowler.
So this basically is very important.
The Martin Fowler and his team,
they have been.
White.
popular in software writing books related
to enterprise architecture,
software engineering,
software development, etc.
You would have seen basically they are
from ThoughtWorks,
but right from Agile Software Development.
To Software Design Architecture Code
Refactory, you go to any concept,
you will see their work and their
information popular,
so many of the other courses also you
might be Software Architecture if you are
studying for sure, you will have.
Martin Fowler's book as a reference, um,
that right, so this...
set of series of articles on harness is
what I'm referring to also,
because that gives a very definite
structure.
So I would recommend all of you read the
complete article in detail,
though I will give a gist of the basic
idea on how harness engineering works.
is achieved or how it should be achieved
in this step.
So they talk about two types of feed
forward and feedback network,
which goes into the harness engineering.
So, basically,
a well-built harness has two main goals:
it.
Increases the probability that the agent
gets the information right in the 1st
place.
It is able to provide what the goal,
what it has to achieve. Second,
it provides a feedback so that the issue
which happened in the first doesn't
happen again.
So it is able to self-correct it and it
is able to recover or reduce those errors,
et cetera.
It should reduce the revenue,
increase the system quality, that's what,
and also should benefit fewer wasted
tokens along the way.
And to harness a coding agent,
they recommend or they anticipate.
Two things: guides,
which are feed-forward controls,
and sensors, which are feedback controls.
Right?
So feed forward guides are which goes
into the agent's behavior and it aims to
steer the agent even before it starts
acting.
So guides are something which we use for
preparation, right?
So even before start doing this task,
guides increase the probability
that the agent creates good results in
the first attempt.
So all the information in the initial
phase goes into the guide.
Sensors are what you observe after the
agent acts on it,
and it helps in the self-correction,
particularly
useful when produced signals that are of
unoptimized.
consumption or how do you optimize for
LLM consumption?
How do you include instructions for
self-correction, etc. Right?
So you get either an agent that keeps
repeating this if you have only a feed
forward.
One, you will have an agent,
even though you are doing it,
an agent will keep repeating the same
mistake, right?
An agent that encodes rules but never
finds out whether they work will be a
feed forward only agent, right?
So the feed forward and feedback should
work.
Together.
Right, and now you also,
so you can see from the diagram that what
goes to feed forward certain principles,
cf parts, certain guides,
how to reference documents.
and basic access to tools,
the different code modes you have, etc.
Right? CFRs are change failure rates,
the percentage of production deployments.
So all these are things which go
initially in the guides based on your
individual enterprise,
your end up software you're working with.
And if you look at the...
Feedback, the analysis,
the observability comes in, the logs,
the agents review, the browser logs, etc.,
static analyzers, etc.
Now we will see another differentiation
that is below inferential and
computational.
So there are two execution types of
guides and sensors.
So I think I touched upon this sometime
earlier also,
that when you have a deterministic and a
faster approach,
you should stick to that and you
shouldn't go for an inferential approach.
Like computational approach are
deterministic, fast. It can run by a CPU.
It doesn't need a GPU. For example,
our static analyzers, our test,
the linter, Skype checkers,
they have been excellent.
Their results are reliable.
They can run with less resources.
They are fast.
They can run in milliseconds.
to seconds and the results are much
reliable.
You don't have to rely on a inferential
system for that.
That is inferential things are semantic
analysis where CPUs or computational
systems don't work well.
Like AI code review, LLM as a judge.
You typically need a GPU.
they are slower and more expensive and
the results are mostly non-deterministic.
So computational guides,
so you can see computational guides is
like you see a settings kind of a symbol.
right?
These are all simple configurations,
right?
They increase the probability of good
results with the deterministic tooling.
Similarly,
computational sensors are cheap and fast
enough to run on every change alongside
an agent.
That is, inferential controls are.
Of course, more expensive,
non-deterministic.
Right?
But they allow us to build a rich
guidance.
We cannot just ignore the inferential
part at all.
They provide a lot of semantic judgment
to one. Inferential sensors,
in spite of them being non-deterministic,
they can increase our trust when used
with a stronger model, et cetera.
So you can, it is, so this is a take away.
Though many of us miss this part,
we concentrate on feed forward.
We know that all these guides should go
and all the sensors should come back.
But it is not all of them should be
inferential.
Some of them can be computational,
some of them can be inferential aspect.
That is the point they stress through,
and...
As I mentioned,
the agent harness acts like a governor.
It guides are sent before the agent acts
and sensors are given after the agent
acts.
And, as I mentioned,
there are two execution mechanisms:
computational, as well as inference. Now,
we will see some examples. OK,
so let's take coding conventions.
Coding convention is feed-forward or...
feedback.
It's feed forward.
It should go before the agent acts, right?
And it is inferential. Okay,
why inferential?
Because the coding conventions,
there can be a semantic meaning which can
come out of it.
So it's more human natural language also.
So that is why it is agents dot MD skills.
All these are example implementations and
inferential in nature.
Instructions on how to bootstrap a new
project. Of course, it's feed forward.
It has to go before the agent acts on it.
But it can be computational or
inferential. Why both?
Anyone can validate this.
Why do you think that it can be both?
Computational log inferential.
The answer is in the example.
Why do you think that bootstrapping a
project can both be computational as well
as inferential?
or what enabled it to be both.
Some standard ways will be there that can
go as general instructions, right?
So how do we bootstrap a project?
Say I ask you to set up a React project.
What do you do?
We can have the steps in a.
md file or it can figure out itself. No,
no,
figure out itself is not an option here.
How do we give the steps as an option?
We will never,
so if you say figure out it itself,
then there is no feed forward here.
So you can remove the feed forward.
That's the guide from there.
That is what it is.
Figure out its own self means you are
removing a guide out of it.
Okay, so the agent will act on its own.
But what I'm talking about here is how
the instruction is given.
So when I say inferential,
it can read natural language.
It's a step of instructions,
as we mentioned, create a repository.
And so when I ask you to start a React
project, you will simply, it will mention,
you will go through some guides and it
will say, it will mention that start a,
create a project, do an NPM install React.
And this is how certain things you will
have to do.
So those are instructions for humans.
plus the systems and it is more
inferential in nature.
But if I give a Docker file.
What it means.
It can be computational, right?
To set up a reactive system,
if I do a Docker file or infrastructure
as a service, I use give a config file.
or I give requirements.
txt and have to install it.
It's computational in nature.
Isn't it?
I don't need an inferential statement to
set up a requirements.
I do an install all the requirements.
txt is going to be installed or I do an
NPM install everything in package.
json has to be installed.
Right,
I don't need a inferential part at all
there.
I don't need someone to tell me what is
this one. The package.
json is going to have the entire set of
files.
So some of you might not be aware of
package.json, et cetera.
So it's like a config file.
It has all the set of libraries.
Everything that is need to run a React
project or a Node.js project.
Right,
so if the instructions is more of natural
language or written in steps,
then we need inferential part.
If it's more code based or if it is a
config file,
then computation itself is sufficient.
So that is why.
For coding conventions,
we say inferential because coding
conventions,
we don't have defined rules or we cannot
accommodate all rules into.
So it's still more of instructions only.
So it's inferential.
But here both possibilities are there,
computational as well as inferential
possibilities are there. That is why.
We have both.
Yeah, and what about code modes?
First of all, what is cold notes?
E.
So port modes are basically,
you can say that it is.
Like.
refactoring. You probably,
I'm not sure if you have got into that
level in software architecture or other
courses, but basically it is like...
refactoring.
You allow code modes to automate
large-scale code to change with precision.
Right,
you rewrite them to when you're dealing
with API changes, when you write,
use abstract syntax trees to automate
large-scale codes, etc. So,
when what is a code node basically is to
tell you in simple words, it's...
basically a modification, but it ran,
there is an automated script which
transforms your code according to a
syntax or according to a coding standard
using abstract syntax tree or defined
rule based specifications, etc.
Have you heard of?
Transpilers.
Anyone heard of transpilers anytime?
Babel.
BABEL Babel Transpiler.
What Babel does, it converts?
Also, see, you will,
I think there is a course on somewhere
you will learn, but let me give a brief.
When you write a code,
the execution engine who is going to
execute that code should know how to
execute that code.
Say I have a Google Chrome browser and
I'm writing a JavaScript code,
but the Google Chrome browser is not
updated to the latest version of
JavaScript.
It's still in a previous version.
There is a newer code I have written
which does which the core JavaScript
compiler will not understand.
So there is a transpiler which translates
the code into a format which is
understood by the browser.
So the JavaScript execution engine of the
browser understands only JavaScript.
It doesn't understand TypeScript.
Or even latest versions of JavaScript
might not be there available.
So the transpiler translates the code
into the JavaScript, right?
So that's what basically code example of
a code code modification.
So they use abstract syntax tree and they
do,
they pass the code into an abstract
syntax tree.
And they modify the tree by applying the
transformation,
and they rewrite the tree back into the
source code, which is.
Required, right?
And this is also required,
and this code mode is completely
computational in nature.
Okay, so there are real, yeah, got it.
So, ma'am.
So you took the example of JavaScript,
right? So in that case,
Yes, ma'am.
no dependency management is required,
so that compiler will automatically do
the changes and so that it will be
understandable.
Are you trying to say that?
No, no,
dependency management is still required.
So all code will not be converted into
JavaScript, right? Libraries,
dependency management are external
libraries which have come as separate
packages which are not in the main
packages.
So,
Babel or this code modes are not
something which will replace the
dependency management.
Okay.
Is that your question? Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that was my question,
whether it'll just...
Say, say I have a React page. OK,
so say this is a simple web page I'm
building with React,
so there will be one basic file.
my master file, my component. OK,
I might use many libraries in this file.
So for example,
I might use a CSS library here.
I might use material UI.
I might also use an API, maybe JSON,
JWT token file here.
So all these are dependencies which will
be there in the package.
json and these are dependencies.
But what I'm talking about as code modes
is when I'm writing this component,
say I write a class component.
or a function component.
So class components are not written
anymore.
So I will write a function component.
When I'm writing this piece of component,
say I'm including an operator.
That operator is not available in the
latest version of JavaScript,
which the browser doesn't understand.
It has to be translated into the version.
which has to be understood by the browser.
That is where transpiler comes in.
Exactly, GURURAJ just mentioned,
you move from one Python version to the
other Python version.
That is also similar to code modes, right?
In JavaScript, the code.
shifts to deprecate calls or there can be
many other,
not only this kind of transformation,
there can be other many things like there
can be many places where we need change,
where we cannot manually go and change
many things.
The structure of...
abstract syntax tree,
the way they call the relationship,
underlying relationship between the
variable,
the identifier would have changed.
So all those things are actually
rewritten. So refactoring,
it all comes under refactoring.
So open rewrite,
is a popular option for Java projects.
It uses a different format of source code
tree and which provides more detailed
information.
in addition to the abstract syntax tree.
So the abstract syntax tree concentrates
only on the syntax structure,
but the open rewrite is something which
focuses on much more information.
It also looks at some semantic meaning,
etc. It's a little more sophisticated.
All these came before the AI era.
where the focus was more on the Java
tools, et cetera. So again,
rewrite offers a library of refactoring
recipes, options, et cetera. Okay,
so if your code has to,
so now this is feedforward because.
The agent has to write code according to
the supported versions,
or it has to rewrite.
That OK, so they have to.
rewrite the exact code. Now, with AI,
this step itself looks so simple,
or the code mode itself looks very
outdated for us because we don't have,
we have AI,
so changing from Python to JavaScript
itself is very easy for us,
but that was not the case, no, without.
before AI. Even versions,
changing to different versions,
a large enterprise software was difficult.
It was large human time consumption work,
and it has to be done with caution.
We didn't have the heterogeneity or
interoperability as smooth as possible.
It was not easy.
to migrate from 3.9 Python to 3.11.
That was not as easy as what it is today.
So that is where this code modes and
other things were quite popular.
That's why we have a whole bunch of work
going on refract.
So,
refactoring is something which developers
did all the time,
making the code maintainable,
making the code extend, etc.
But all this today looks a little more
simpler,
or the shift of software engineers is
changing from doing this kind of heavy
shift, heavy work.
coding work to doing more design oriented
thinking related steps. Right. So,
but since it is rule based,
or I would say it is more of based on
abstract syntax tree and it is all rules,
it is computational in nature.
OK, and test.
All of us know what tests unit tests our
fixed test,
so it's just execution test of,
but it is feedback, it is not feedforward,
it runs after the you have a set of tests
which have already written,
you are changing something in your code,
you want to ensure that the changed.
code passes all the tests which you have
written.
Right, so this is computational in nature.
It's not in French.
How to review instructions of how to
review, of course, feedback.
How do you review?
Maybe how do you do a certain kind of
verification reviews, et cetera.
And since this is going to be in set of
instructions, it's inferential in nature.
Okay, a few examples just to...
Show you that.
Harness building harness is more of
software engineering.
Ape.
And the human's job here is to steer the
agent by iterating on the arms whenever
an issue happens multiple times.
The feed forward and feedback control
should be improved to make the issue less
probable to occur the next time or even
prevent it.
So the steering loop,
so you can see there is a loop which will
come here.
Right, so,
so this is not going to happen one time,
so the loop is...
given there to ensure how we can use AI
to improve the harness continuously.
And coding agents now make it much
cheaper to build custom controls and
custom static analyzers, etc.
So agents can help also write.
So building these guides and sensors also
agents can help to write structural tests,
generate draft rules from observed
patterns, etc. And this can continue.
Right?
So I would recommend all of you read this
particular article without fail.
I hope it answered the question.
Voice is breaking.
Which category does unit test sits in?
I didn't, uh,
you're asking about harness engineering
or?
You're asking which direction unit test
is feedback.
And it is computational, of course.
E.
Is my voice clear till now?
Yes, ma'am.
Okay, so...
Where harness engineering fits in the AI
stSemAIMLstudentsdocs? What do you think?
What should be your answer if I ask where
harness engineering fits in the AI
stSemAIMLstudentsdocs?
planning design throughout all phases,
every stage, yes.
So it's not a separate discipline to
offsite to a particular phase, okay?
It lives inside the entire SDLC.
The life cycle, how AI assisted,
wherever we are going to use AI assisted
software.
Then.
or AI assistance in doing the SDLC phase.
Right? Arnas will comment.
Some teams call this agentic SDLC because
agents do the execution and humans govern
the checkpoints. But basically,
that's one.
When to use harness?
Whenever a single turn chat assistant
answers questions and polls no stage,
the moment an agent starts to act and not
just answer, the entire calculus changes.
So the clearest signal is whenever you
are giving autonomy.
Whenever you are giving access more than
to a chat bot,
that is where harness will come in.
A real harness need to exist even before
the agent starts feed forward,
and it also needs to be there before
after the agent does it.
So the more autonomy the agent has,
the more irreversible its actions are,
the more harness you have to do it.
Right?
So I gave you some examples of harness
components, the guides and sensors,
but it is not limited to that.
So system prompts, skills, tools,
MCP connections, schemas,
coding conventions, all these are harness.
Um...
The guides and sensors,
all these are harness which we are
building around the agent, right? So,
in each phase in the planning space,
work gets...
scope context gets assembled.
So context management decides what the
agent sees before it starts, right?
So now harness engineering is leading us
to the context engineering.
So all the guides.
we are providing, right?
That is the context.
That is part of the context.
It is not the entire context.
That's part of the context we are
providing to the agent.
So how do we provide that context to the
agent?
That is where harness engineering comes
in. Then during building,
the agent generates the code or takes an
action. What tools it can have, what CLI,
whether it can run the CLI command,
Whether the code which is returned
follows the coding conventions,
does it have has it entered in the audit
trail?
All these are guardrails, tools,
orchestration, guardrails.
So this is what harness engineering
should concentrate on build phase.
When it comes to review,
that the agent is checking the work,
sensors such as linters, test,
what are the tests,
catch problems before they ship,
all that is what harness matters about.
When the agent goes to production or when
the software goes to production,
approval gates,
are there human in the loop points,
or what runs automatically,
what waits for human confirmation,
how long,
what are the metrics it should deploy to.
So all that is what it looks at.
So at each.
Face.
The harness at the team, the organization,
every the single agent harness described
mostly I have been discussing is
necessary.
But it is not only the one sufficient one,
right?
So when you look at multi-agent system,
the harness expands its capability.
Like a context lake is a knowledge of
organizational knowledge, deployments,
dependencies on call schedules.
So there will be multiple agents who will.
..
be acting on it.
right? So you should keep it up to date.
You should not,
one agency is a partial or a stale data,
it might take up out a wrong picture of
the information. Then integrations,
how it connects with external systems,
right?
And access controls and permissions.
All that has to be there.
So before going into context engineering,
now this step leads us to the term
context engineering.
But before going to context engineering,
I just want to talk about a few
Mistakes, harness mistakes,
or simple mistakes which is made, right?
Hardness is not just wrong thing that we
have to remember.
Many people, a system prompt,
they think that what all we discussed as
guides, et cetera,
can go into a system prompt or treating
the entire whole harness as a system
prompt. There are no tools,
there are no checks, just instructions.
The model can,
if you're just giving it to the model,
it can easily drift from that
instructions.
So the fix on the harness engineering has
to have real guides and sensors,
not just prompting.
So harness engineering is not prompt
engineering.
So that is 1 take away point because many
times the most common mistake is give all
the information in terms of system prompt
or user prompt and the model will work
out.
It will not.
It can easily drift from instructions.
So we have to have guardrails.
We have to have real sensors, real guides.
Next is verification loop.
So no verification is not at all
acceptable. Sensors are,
guides are alone not sufficient.
Sensors are mandatory.
So a review step is necessary.
So the harness has to concentrate on
sensors.
No code should enter a production without
a sensor.
Checking it.
The 3rd is on permissions.
Usually we have broad permissions for
convenience.
Giving an agent standing access to
production can be more dangerous.
So you have to clearly spoke permissions
to exactly what the task needs.
and not a broader permission.
Right,
and context is a very short-term memory,
what the model sees at that point of time.
But there are many things which needs to
be in persistent memory.
That is where guides and other things
will come in.
So when you don't have a persistent
memory,
a mistake the team caught in the last
iteration or last month occurs again this
month.
and you have not encoded the fix anywhere
where the agent would see it again.
So you correct it in that chat or prompt
or you correct it in that cycle.
So you see the mistake,
you immediately prompt it to change that
and it goes away.
The context of that agent.
corrects it,
but it doesn't get corrected in the
future iterations.
In order to get it corrected in the
future iteration,
it should go from the short-term memory
to the long-term memory,
which is the guides and the persistent
memory.
Whatever you are giving in the context at
that prompt time during the prompt,
et cetera, is a short-term memory.
It will solve the problem,
but it will not ensure that the problem
will not occur in the future.
OK,
so you have to work on the feedback which
is coming,
and you should improve your guides such
that the problem doesn't occur in the
future,
so that is an important point we have to.
That is revisiting the harness.
Controls built for a small task stay in
place.
You never review the harness whenever the
agent's responsibility changes or it
grows or you have to revisit when the
scope changes.
Okay, so before going context engineering,
one more word on cost I have to talk
about.
So the token economics of white coding
versus AI engineering.
The case for harness engineering is not
about reliability, it is also about
Cost,
so the cost argument is where the
difference between byte coding and agent
engineering becomes more concrete, right?
When I say byte coding,
it is the upfront cost is completely zero;
you are putting everything in a prompt,
the real.
Cost shows up later,
and it compounds right,
but without a harness,
what are you actually doing?
You are dumping a large,
unstructured file into a context window
and asks the model to fix something,
and when this fix is strong, they...
You re-prompt it,
and every retry is burning tokens,
and the retry loop becomes deep,
long sessions, etc.,
because the model is carrying tons and
thousands of tokens, system prompts,
files, etc.
Right,
but if you take white coding or you just
doing a prompting and correcting it,
it doesn't have something which doesn't,
I'm saying white coding because it
doesn't have any harness around it.
That's what I'm meaning to.
Or we can also ignore that and say when
there is no harness, there is no capex.
Lost.
And a large,
unpredictable builds is what we get based
after reviewing, retrying, et cetera.
But when you build with a harness,
real harness,
which brings in a shape to your cycle,
SDLC development cycle.
Harness has a CapEx investment.
You bring in some upfront cost,
like you write guides,
you define tool schemas,
you set up context pipelines,
and the upfront cost buys down the
marginal cost.
It brings down the marginal cost at every
run at some point later.
So on-demand context.
keeps the token spent check because the
model is not going to reread the RAJ
files again and again.
And there are going to be guardrails and
sensors which can catch errors.
So the computational part which we were
talking about,
so these are not going to cost or burn
tokens for you.
So that is going to save, it is going to,
there is going to be guard rails which
prevent you to enter into a retry loop
again and again, right? And there are,
you are going to revisit the guides and
you are going to fix certain errors
permanently.
So the same mistake doesn't happen again
and again. So the cost is going to.
come down,
but it is going to be both CapEx as well
as OpEx cost and it is not going to be
only the token burning cost in the bills
we get.
That's exactly the difference when you
have hardness and when you don't have
hardness around it.
Right?
So this leads us to the context
engineering.
So what exactly we have seen context
window already. So anything that,
how do you provide that information?
That is what is context engineering.
How does harness relate to context
engineering?
How do you make those guides and sensors
available to the agent?
How well you define them,
how do you make them available is what,
how do you provide the structured
information to the LLM to produce the
reliable output is what context
engineering is about.
Okay, so this two,
three lines exactly defines what a
context engineering is like, right?
So there is one small window.
of data or information which the LLM can
react to.
So what information you fill into that
context so that the output in LLM gives
you the best result,
that is what context engineering.
So that is why they say context
engineering is both art and science.
Okay, whenever there is a design,
when a decision making comes into picture,
we don't tell it as science.
We say it is art, right?
Designing is an art.
Designing software itself is an art.
Designing an API structure is an art
because it is, there's no...
predefined or there is no fixed one
solution. There are multiple options.
You decide, you look at the trade-offs,
you look at the benefits,
you look at the disadvantages,
and then you decide what information
should go into the context window or what
right information
to ensure that the agent reaches its goal.
Right,
so this is what they say: LLMs are the
new operating system.
LLM is like the CPU and the context
window is like the RAM serving the
model's working memory.
So like we have a limited capability on
RAM and we have multiple algorithms,
right? We have a round drop in,
we use serve the first come first.
So what the shortest time task is
executed first.
There are multiple algorithms, right?
So similarly,
context engineering is about how do you
place the right context into the window?
to ensure that the LLM answers your WILP.
Right.
So now what all of you know what is
context engineering, right?
So context engineering,
we know what is context window also,
what is the limit?
So what all goes into the context window,
I think I discussed in the previous class,
the system prompt, user query,
any documents.
data retrieved from structured data, CSVs,
all that, right?
So context engineering involves what
information,
how do you structure that information in
real time?
Like LLMs, as I mentioned,
they don't have a long-term memory.
They have a short-term memory.
That is the context window.
So the quality and structure of the
context window directly influences the
model's reason.
So despite the speed and ability to
manage large volumes of data,
LLNs has problems like humans have.
They lose focus.
Last time I discussed a problem,
needle in a haystick,
benchmarking and all.
content rot is a problem.
There is a diminishing middle layer which
the context misses.
So as the number of contexts increases,
the model's ability to accurately recall
information from the context decreases.
So there are certain capabilities we have.
So LLMs have an attention budget.
So that is where context engineering will
play a major role. So you look at steps.
What are the steps you have to look at is
how do you select the content?
How do you structure?
How do you put it to the LLM through
prompt and design?
How do you compress certain things?
How do you integrate it with other tools?
All the steps you have to look at in
context engineering.
Okay, so now Abhinav has asked question,
what is the difference between prompt
engineering and context engineering?
So that is where.
I would say that the context engineering
encompasses 2 closely related techniques,
prompt engineering and retrieval of
Augmented generation, the RAG model.
Right, so.
What you give to the user, sorry,
what you give to the LLM,
everything is a prompt.
K.
So, what is the difference between...
Context and prompt this.
Whatever we give has instructions.
To the.
model as a system prompt or user prompt.
Those are the instructions based on which
it designs what it needs to respond to.
And all the other information which goes,
what role it should play or what data it
have access to, all that is the context.
So but all this together is what is the
context window fits in.
Right?
So context engineering is a series of
steps where prompt engineering is one
part of it. How instructions are framed,
how you include them,
how do you format them and provide it to
the LLM model, that's prompt.
So prompt engineering is much narrower.
That is, in case of.
context engineering, it is much more.
So designing the instruction,
the formatting tone,
and there are a few prompt strategies.
So the model will understand the
immediate request using the prompter.
Assembling and curating everything that
fills the context window,
like the conversation state,
the retrieved documents,
the dynamic tools, the metadata,
all these guides, et cetera,
the caching information, compression,
noise reduction,
all that is context engineering.
So the context is what goes
into the system.
And harness is how do you manage the
software runtime around the model?
How do you provide this?
How do you ensure that the agent app gets
the context plus accesses all this?
How it runs the CLI,
evaluating how it handles infrastructure.
How it, how the response after it comes,
how it is checked, et cetera.
So that is our Ms.
So it started with prompt engineering.
So earlier we were focusing by coding
when it came in.
We all know that through just by...
Giving instructions,
we can build an entire software.
And then came prompt engineering,
where we said that if you just talk to a
model in terms of how you talk to your
friend or a co-developer, it will not.
You have to structure the prompt,
so use prompt strategy.
So I will discuss a few prompting
strategies next class.
I have a few slides, but I will not.
So the prompting strategies were brought
in.
So how do you talk to users in a way that
the model can respond better?
Like they are all pre-trained on certain
data, so they can,
you are improving the context by giving
better prompts.
So that is where prompt engineering
stopped.
But context engineering is a little above.
So you select which context,
because the context window is a small box.
What you put into the box directly
reflects the output.
So you have to carefully put what has to
be there into the context.
So you have to select it,
you have to structure it.
it,
you have to also ensure the instructions
are going clearly and you have to do a
set of steps that is context engineering.
But giving the context and getting the
output alone is not sufficient.
right, you have to have guardrails.
How do you give the context?
How do you manage the external tools?
How the agent uses the external runtime,
how it interacts with other API tools,
environment, et cetera.
That is where harness came into picture.
So that's the difference between prompt,
context, and partners.
So if you look at the steps in context
engineering, I will stop with this slide.
So it starts with the context selection,
choosing what information to include in
the context.
Filtering out irrelevant,
redundant information,
reducing the context window to support
the current task, right?
And structuring is about how all
information is organized and given
clearly to the.
LLM,
so you can use data formats like JSON or
markdown files to provide defined
instructions,
and you can also improve on the prompting
aspects, right?
There are many prompting techniques,
like few-shot learning, one-shot learning,
etc. So, instructions are...
framed,
the constraints and rules are included,
so there can be examples provided so that
the model understands very well.
For example, if I ask...
Let's say I want to design a question for
your exam.
I ask LLM to give me a question on
agentic systems.
It will randomly give some question.
But if I have a sample question and I say
build a question like this,
similar to this,
then it will give me a very perfect
example.
So that is like one shot learning.
So I'm giving it,
it doesn't work only on what data it
learned during its training phase,
but it is also learning something from
the prompt I'm doing,
and it is providing me the answer.
So that is what prompt design and
engineering is all about.
And then you also include techniques for
fitting more useful information within
the token space.
So how do you handle data compression
like Huffman coding?
Or you include techniques like
summarization?
to ensure that LLM's memory only contains
relevant information.
So that is context compression.
And ordering is very important.
That is where sequencing comes.
So you should send guides first.
What guide you should send first?
How should the,
which rules should go first?
Or what is the most relevant one at this
point of time?
and less information can go in the future
context window.
So that kind of sequencing is also
important. And finally,
the tool and memory integration. How,
when the current context or model
training doesn't contain the required
information, how it can
call a tool,
call an external API to get that
information or what it can refer to,
what guides it can refer to.
That is the tool and memory integration.
So overall context engineering,
we'll talk about retrieval generation.
processing and pre-processing and
management. Okay,
so I'll talk about this in the next class.
Since it's almost time,
I will stop here today.
So the transition is harness context,
and then I will move to prompt
engineering and RANGNATH.
That was the transition.
So I will stop here today.
I will continue the next session.